January 11 2017 Ukrainian efforts to
sabotage Trump backfire Kiev officials
are scrambling to make amends with the
president-elect after quietly working to
boost Clinton that quote the article
political then our concern Ukrainian
government officials trying to help
Hillary and undermine Trump to publicly
question his fitness for office they
disseminated documents implicating a top
trump aide in corruption suggested they
were investigating the matter a
ukrainian American operative was
consulting for the DNC met with these
officials in the Ukrainian embassy in DC
in an effort to expose ties etc etc to
the Trump campaign Paul Manta for Russia
and in the end the Ukrainian efforts had
an impact in the race helping to force
Manta forts resignation advancing the
narrative blah blah blah mr. mayor thank
you for being with us
joining us now Senate Judiciary Chairman
Lindsey Graham senator good to see you
your reaction to all of this I would
invite what a vice president United
States of America hold out a billion
dollars and say you got six hours fire
that prosecutor our Ukrainian prosecutor
or else you're not getting the billion
why would he ever do that
I can imagine if Mike Pence did that you
might be hearing more about it but the
whistleblower investigation has been
sent to the intelligence community we'll
look at all things by now hope somebody
outside of politics will do to the Biden
team what they did to Trump look at it
really hard and see if a crime was
committed but here's what bothers me
tonight this New York Times article
about bar talking to Australia is the
beginning of an effort to solid yeah
it's the beginning of an effort to shut
down bars investigation to find out how
this whole thing started and let me tell
you why I want to say on national
television bars should be talking to
Australia he should be talking to Italy
he should be talking to the UK to find
out if their intelligence services work
with our intelligence services
improperly to open up a
counterintelligence investigation of
Trump's campaign if he's not doing that
not doing his job so I'm going to write
a letter to all three countries and
asking them to cooperate with bar now
this is a letter sent by my Democratic
colleagues in May of 2018 to the Ukraine
saying that if you don't cooperate with
a Muller investigation we're going to
stop our aid so here's why I wanna marry
people to know it's okay to cooperate
with Muller to get Trump but it's not
okay to cooperate with bar to find out
if Trump was a victim of an
out-of-control intelligence operation
we're not going to have a country like
that senator do you believe as I believe
eventually the evidence will show and
what will probably emerge into a durum
or durum bar or report at some point
that high-ranking intelligence officials
not the rank-and-file people that keep
us safe every day in part there are two
issues here they took turning the
powerful tools of intelligence against
the American people but do you believe
those three specific countries Australia
Italy Great Britain that there was a
specific outsourcing of illegal spying
in other words they subcontracted spying
right that ain't no an order to
circumvent American laws they said we
use spy on this person for me do you
believe that likely happen I don't know
but I know we're going to find about out
about that in two weeks and I think bars
should be looking that but I want to
make this point really clear this store
at times there article is an effort to
stop bar from looking at how this whole
thing began in 2016 regarding the Trump
campaign what are they afraid of this
really bothers me a lot that the left is
going to try to say there's something
wrong with bar talking to Australia
Italy and the United Kingdom if you're
worried about foreign people being
involved in our election so you ought to
be worried about Christopher still being
hired by the Democratic Party and here's
my question is this whistleblower
whoever he or she may be do they have
any connection to the intelligence
community the old intelligence community
that was corrupt as hell they're CIA
agents out there risking their lives for
American patriots but Brennan and
clapper
I am hoping and praying that somebody
will look at
the way the counterintelligence
investigation against the Trump campaign
began was it based on evidence that
Papadopoulos was working with the
Russians or was it based on stuff coming
from countries friendly does you know
the president when he was speaking with
President szalinski which never should
be leaked because no foreign leader is
ever going to want to talk on a phone
with our president right and we need
that to happen for the safety and
security but you know when the president
says all I need a favor
you know we've had these election
problems and you guys seem to be in the
center of it all and we even have
political outlining here that they were
admitting that they helped Hillary
Clinton and they were trying to make
amends for the work that they did to
sabotage our elections I thought
everybody in the media cared about that
up and oh but it's only if it's Donald
Trump that's right it doesn't matter if
it's Hillary Stasi and it doesn't matter
Ukraine is telling us they did it they
influenced our election that there were
Democratic operatives that went to them
and colluded with them for the purpose
of getting damaging information and that
pretty clear in that political article
to you sir well it's very clear that a
couple of things are clear that
Democrats wanted the Ukraine to work
with Muller and if they didn't they
would cut off their aid it's clear to me
that liberals are starting an attack
against Barr to shut him down from going
to Italy Australia and the UK to find
out if there was something wrong
regarding opening up the investigation
of the Trump campaign to begin with if
that's not a double standard I don't
know what would be so - Attorney General
bar you're doing the country a great
service we're trying to find out what
happened in 2016 regarding a
counterintelligence investigation of the
Trump campaign these countries should be
cooperating with bar there's nothing
wrong for bar looking into this as a
matter of fact it would be wrong if he
didn't so I'm a Republican senator is
going to write to these three countries
urging them to cooperate with bar when
are we going to finally get the IG
report senator on FISA abuse because
well I said it's funny but a couple
because we know that that was an
unverifiable in a couple CA and it's a
dirty Russian dossier
you know you think about this senator
you think okay well
they care about election interference
the political right here they talk about
what Ukraine did to interfere in the
2016 election they didn't care about
Russian interference with Hillary's
dirty dice eiated the mob right or the
Democrats didn't care that she screwed
what poor Bernie out of a primary they
didn't care that they rigged an
investigation she clearly obstructed
justice I think if I deleted it
subpoenaed emails I'd be in deep deep
you know what so what about the double
standard in all this
well what about whether or not the
whistleblower people around the
whistleblower were tied to the folks
that opened up the investigation against
Trump to begin with we'll see all right
senator thank you for being with us